So können Sie mit dem Nebler umgehen. Wie
läuft es? Nun, wir sind sehr aufgeregt,
eigentlich kommen unsere Filme in ein
paar Wochen heraus, also ist es eine aufregende Zeit, wir
haben morgen Abend eine große Firmenparty
und es ist aufregend, ok, es sind auch 25
Jahre Pizza  Es ist 25 Jahre her, dass wir der 12.
Spielfilm sind, was sehr aufregend ist, also ist
es erstaunlich, wenn man bedenkt, dass wir in 25 Jahren
12 Filme gemacht haben, es ist ein großes Jahr
für uns, ok, was ist das Aufregendste, wenn
Sie einen neuen Film für sich haben?  nur sie
wollen, was die Leute sagen würden oder was
das Aufregendste im Film ist. Wissen Sie,
was für Sie?
Die Zusammenarbeit
mit John Lasseter war unglaublich. Ich
fühle mich wirklich glücklich und geehrt,
mit ihm zusammengearbeitet zu haben, und Sie wissen, dass ich wahrscheinlich
eigentlich noch wichtiger war, dass
wir ein wirklich großartiges Team hatten, also habe ich es geliebt
, jeden Tag zur Arbeit zu kommen
und mit so talentierten Menschen zusammenzuarbeiten  Leute es
rea  Es hat wirklich Spaß gemacht, es war schwer,
Spaß zu haben, okay, es gibt mehrere Projektionsfirmen
auf der Welt, die produzieren 3D-
Filme. Stuckpixel waren eine der ersten,
und es gibt einen Unterschied zu anderen Filmen
zu denken, dass ich meine, dass ich unsere
Filme liebe. Ich liebe die Sorgfalt und Rücksichtnahme
, die Pixar in den Prozess des Geschichtenerzählens
investiert
Seien Sie einfach stolz darauf,
dass wir versuchen, bei jedem Film unser Bestes zu geben,
und ich bin einfach stolz darauf, hier ein
Teil des Teams zu sein, warum produzieren Sie
diese Filme auf diese Weise und nicht und nicht
eine Sekunde eine Sekunde und  Bitte machen Sie einen
Schnitt von der Erde und wir könnten und warum nicht
billig und schnell, ähm, ich meine, für mich war
es schnell, um ehrlich zu sein, weil
wir diesen Film letztes Jahr tatsächlich in einem gemacht haben,
also hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es wirklich schnell ging. Ich
denke, das interessiert uns  darüber, jedem
eine wirklich großartige, Sie wissen schon, wunderbare
Quali zu geben  ty Film, der bei
Leuten ankommen kann, bei den Zuschauern weißt du, es geht nicht
darum, es schnell und billig zu machen, sondern
darum, es gut und richtig zu machen,
und ich weiß nicht, okay, was
richtig ist, was richtig ist, ist, dass
wir wirklich hart an der Geschichte arbeiten  und Sie
wissen,
dass das die große Herausforderung war, ein Jahr weniger zu haben, war,
dass ich einfach sicherstellen wollte, dass
jeder genug Zeit hatte, um die
Geschichte reifen zu lassen und so gut wie möglich zu sein,
also für mich als Produzent  Bei dem Film
weißt du, das war das, worüber ich mir Sorgen machte,
als sie ein Jahr Pause brauchten, und du
weißt, wir machen den Film acht Mal, was
andere Leute, glaube ich, nicht
machen  die szenen wir nehmen scratch
dialoge soundeffekte musik temp music auf
und stellen sie auf und reißen sie auseinander und wir
machen das achtmal also hab ich mal vorgetäuscht ja
ja warum soll man daraus einen tollen film machen und ich
denke das ist teil der magie des
prozesses  dass es nur getan wird,
um die Geschichte großartig zu machen  Ist das ein
Pizza-Geheimnis, oh, ich weiß nicht, du weißt, es gibt
kein Geheimnis, es ist harte Arbeit, du
weißt, ich denke, das hilft auf jeden Fall
Menschen zu haben, die sich kümmern, und das
macht wirklich einen Unterschied, es ist
die Kultur, wenn ein Buch und nein, ich denke,
es ist, ich denke, es ist die Kultur, weil
wir Sie wissen, was
ich an der Arbeit hier liebe, ist, dass sich jeder
wirklich darum kümmert  und wir haben eine Kultur
, um das Beste daraus zu machen, ich meine manchmal bis zu
dem Punkt, an dem man den Leuten sagen muss,
dass es
gut genug ist, dass man nichts mehr tun muss
, und ich denke, dass jeder,
der einen Film machen will, einen machen muss, den man kann
Darauf können wir alle stolz sein, es ist einfach
in der Kultur verwurzelt, also weiß ich nicht,
okay, vielen Dank, aber ich denke, Sie
haben uns gesagt, was der Unterschied
zwischen Pixeln und anderen ist, aber Sie
wissen, was ich ehrlich gesagt hasse
Um Sie zu unterbrechen, aber ich denke, wir
alle alle das  arbeitet im Filmgeschäft,
jeder möchte an einem großartigen Film arbeiten,
und ich denke, Sie wissen, dass es
enttäuschend ist
Um ehrlich zu sein, zum Glück nicht bei Pixar, und
das ist wirklich der Grund, warum ich
hierher gekommen bin, weil ich es leid war, an schlechten
Filmen zu arbeiten, und ich und ich respektierten einfach die
Art von Antrieb und Ehrgeiz und den Wunsch
, großartige Filme zu machen, aber niemand will es
gegenüber niemandem tun  macht sich daran einen schlechten film zu machen
okay vielen dank dir sicher